[Music]
all right welcome back to mandalay bay
game one of the best of five series it's
the aces taking on the mercury joining
me is the owner of the aces mark this is
a lot of fun when you think of what this
team has done this season with the
olympics and now back and into the
semifinals great year for the aces now
it's been fantastic it's been kind of
chopped up chris uh with the starting
the season taking the break for the
olympics getting the four gold medals on
this team uh then coming back and
playing a little bit and taking again it
feels like been forever since the season
ended and now here we go into the
playoffs what it's all about you know in
this team there's seven players that
have averaged double figures which is
unheard of yeah and they've been very
unselfish and sharing it and uh
understanding what it is that builds a
team and i think we've got a team here
you are always on the front row you've
been here at every game you are like a
dream owner for these players and for
the wnba how's that going well as long
as we win that's what it's all about you
know we're here for that now
the season was great
they focused i texted bill after they uh
clinched the number two spot and i said
i never thought i'd be happy saying
we're number two but we're number two
and what that gives us is the
opportunity to have a home game two home
games here to open up this series the
semifinals series and uh with our
fantastic fan base we've got a home
field advantage well mark good luck
tonight we appreciate you stopping by
thanks chris appreciate it there he is
the owner of the aces and the raiders mr
mark davis